[Music]
so you know how everyone says that
eventually one day robots are going to
take over the world and
humans are not going to have jobs
because robots are taking robots already
took over my bedroom
and i wouldn't have it any other way you
mean like a vibrator you're calling geo
a robot
that's my friend my sex world my [ __ ]
friend
oh what the [ __ ] are you talking about
geo are you calling her a robot i have a
sex robot that replaced geo
oh when she's tired and doesn't want to
deal with you yeah well that's when she
runs out of batteries
and she just lays there no yeah so
well there is some hope out there for
the humans
solar powered sex robots because now you
don't have to charge them oh that's so
convenient but you can't do it in dark
places
how long can it hold it only tropical
you just have to like leave her outside
we're gonna shine a flashlight on her
eyes and hopefully it charges i mean but
how would you even get the doll sent out
there i like the [ __ ] outside so that's
good how would you get the robot center
no you don't i wish you weren't here for
that
oh damn it i want it
well uh the hope here is that the
hardware the ho
ho ho ho all right no so walmart
has just recently scrapped their plans
to have robots scan
shelves and they decided that humans can
just do the job like
it's just it works so they've had this
partnership with this one robotics
company for the past five years
and they have gradually added six foot
tall inventory scanning machines to the
stores
and it was like one of their major
points like the major topics that they
would always use
when they would be talking about like
talking to their investors and stuff
but now at this point especially with
the pandemic they realize that
human workers are just as effective if
not more effective because they walmart
has been
experiencing a lot of out of stock
inventory and so they're like the [ __ ]
robots
are you doing your job or not are they
supposed to stock the inventory they're
supposed to keep scan
people forget you likes a person has to
program the robot to do its job so
somebody didn't do their job because
they didn't garbage in garbage out not
necessarily
saying that the robots were doing a bad
job it's more like the humans can just
do the same job
and it's fine we don't need to we don't
need to continuously
have robots come in and replace human
workers but they're more expensive
humans yeah the labor costs it does cost
human steel walmart is competing with
amazon
and you know they're just trying to be
friendly and keep people working there
because they still want to
compete that's what i think that's what
i think they want to be the
company with a heart this is the robots
that they are no longer going to be
implementing and robots don't do
graffiti in the bathroom
during what employees do walmart has
been
the store to employ everybody for a
long time walmart is shitty to employees
they've gone through so many like
lawsuits
as far as what they depict this has
nothing to do with what runs down but
they show you know like they have the
greeters and they have all these jobs
and they create opportunities
so if walmart goes and employs all these
robots they're no longer walmart but
where do these
robots go now they go outside they got
to be under a ditch or something they're
homeless robots that's mean
like benders they're under an overpass
or robots that'd be a cute story they
should have painted the robot like
better
you know would be messed up if he wore a
vest that would be great
that'll be dumb he's the best
that's like the nicest walmart i've ever
seen okay let's be real when you guys
walk through walmart with your receipt
do you think they're actually reading
that thing
no they just called costco i had a guy
that actually took his job seriously and
he would highlight every single item and
i was like damn this is the first time
you must get bullied or he just thought
you look shady yeah he thought you were
actually stealing
he's like you're gonna steal you pal let
me check this
out has anyone been stopped at costco
like yo
i don't know if this is this adds up
never you know what's
tight about costco is there's so many
filipinos that go there so i
used to just sneak in with a family like
i'm just thinking at the end of one but
then how do you preach
samples yeah mickey's accent gets super
strong all of a sudden excuse me don't
worry
i'm going in with them for these samples
today
but don't worry now we're members not to
not to flash to you wow
we're members now we're official club
members
i think my ex is still paying for ours
oh wow
you know what happened we were talking
about i was talking about it with my
co-host once and he was like
i'll put you on mine so you don't have
to deal with it anymore and he's like
don't worry i'll never kick you off
that's cute that's sweet yeah i was like
well
okay i'll i'll take it i still need to
get big bags of dog foods
can i join i just want to be on it i've
never shopped at costco
just have somebody sponsor ours they
have good deals can somebody just
sponsor can we have joint accounts
that's true that's that'll be you said
we need to maximize this yeah that's
understandable
it's like how they uh sponsor like
weddings and stuff
oh my god do you want to give her a
question
[Music]
we have all these memberships dope my
yoga membership is expensive so we need
to get that because you need me in shape
you need what do you need i need a
motorcycle
he needs a motorcycle so we need clothes
the the gear the jackets the motorcycle
club that you're going to be a member of
i like costco hot dogs oh i love costco
hottest those you can get on the outside
though i'm going to oh really yeah you
just get a discount if you remember
yeah well no but some cocktails have it
on the inside it's [ __ ] oh wow
but i'm a member now it's on caribou
we're going to need my therapy sessions
okay deal with this relationship i'm
going to have to go to therapy so we're
going to use that
you're going to have to go to therapy
after you've been eating his butt for a
year right that's true
they have good tequila one of the they
do have good skin one of
our first interactions was him showing
me what a trusty uh uh rusty trombone
that's true that sounds right no i just
like jesus i gotta do what again like
good thing i have long arms what is a
rusty trombone again it sounds like
something to do with the butthole
and maybe when you play the when you
when you play the dick like a trombone
he showed me he acted it out i was on
the couch
and i gave her a step by step yeah tim
caught it all on
on his camera that was like our first
real
date wow you kind of had a couch right
i was like listen so i go into what
honey why don't we do anything like this
because they call it rusty trombone for
a reason do you empty this
it took me forever to see his butt that
spit bow yeah the spit valve of the
trombone
oh the saliva is coming out no
no i used to play the trumpet so
she's got experience except except i
don't go like this i go like this
but that wouldn't feel good he hasn't
complained yet
you do that on a dick yeah no it doesn't
feel good
it's like a massage can you imagine this
what are you doing just trying bonus i
just want to be first chair
oh god you know you're you know you've
been in band when you make jokes like
yeah dude were you ever first chair i
was actually a first chair trumpet
player and was in marching band
oh dude in high school i would have
kicked your ass i was a nerd
that i played sports i got to see your
high school pictures i was
here's the thing i look the same
i went to a really i went to a really
small school so being in
activities wasn't like a loser or weirdo
thing like everybody did yeah
we were in honor roll we played band
played sports in art
it wasn't like i was in band um in
junior high and it was like all it was
cool yeah it was cool people did it and
my mom was like when i was in school
band was for geeks and then american pie
came out in that same year and yeah
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] and then in high
school
i tried joining the band and i was like
oh i see it now
and then i dropped out i don't even
recognize bandos as people
i don't know you were in band you
[ __ ] nerd i was not i was i was in
band briefly
okay what was he twirling i hate when
she's here why does she have to be here
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] i wish you
weren't here
i played the trumpet but i copied off my
friend the whole time he couldn't really
play
i played trumpet too in fifth grade wow
you hypocrite
that's a three-kier well no that's when
i decided i hate mando's forever
actually because i had to
because he used to be one wow i would
have taken you for a clarinet
would win so my sister's a woodwind
clarinet player yeah
like squidward steve wasn't the stick
that stick twirler
i could have done it because i am a
leader
when anybody was in band and you look at
like why would you choose that
instrument like i looked at this one
girl and she played trombone and i was
like
[ __ ] you never want to get none like
what made you
what she was teaching me dude tuba kids
were always the same kind of person
they look like the instrument yeah the
girls percussionist
yeah the girls that play drums were just
such badasses i was the only girl that
played trumpet because there was no
other girls i played why was it always
the big boy that did it
the tuba i don't know because he could
carry it
because he went in the parade i knew a
tuba kid who had a two-bit
dad who played tuba all the [ __ ] time
and they had a tubelicious
family and they lived in tubaville dude
it was wild
i want to hear a tuba solo like they
don't get enough like
of its own shine when an overweight
character walks by in an old movie
did you guys ever notice like the flu
players they were always like super soft
like little pixies i always wanted to
play i played flute and then i
upgraded to piccolo because no one else
played piccolo only one person could
and it's the same movements as flute but
it's just tiny dude what about the
triangle guide though
the triangle guy is basically like man i
know i don't really have a future here
he's like
my mom i play triangle in junior high
did you
yeah symbols was sick but again you're
not gonna get hired for much
you know too much about band i just
always
wanted to be in a cool marching band
yeah
it never happened while your bedroom
marching band was whack we
won things and
but it wasn't i played the [ __ ]
trumpet i don't know
you wanted to be like drumline with nick
cannon yeah why did you choose the
trumpet
because no i'm gonna be the only girl
doing it yeah because there was no other
girls that played there was already a
girl
drummer and somebody else already took
everything else and i was like
well you didn't choose it for the
instrument no [ __ ] no dude i wanted to
i did i wanted to play sex i wanted to
play saxophone yeah
it was too expensive my mom's like [ __ ]
no oh my god we definitely did payments
on my trumpet and i had to give it back
our school had a uh they just gave it to
us
yeah like they i don't know they paid
for everything yeah isaac's old school
it was a public school yeah gave it to
isaac
because he's been playing trumpet for
the last three years with someone else's
mouth on it yeah ours was like that too
but you buy the reed or the bite you buy
them buy it
how do you see practice did does he just
practice on the mouthpiece
uh in the house no no no he has the
whole instrument he'll practice with the
entire instrument but then now in this
new school we had to
rent like get it ourselves and i'm like
what yeah we had to
yeah i still i want to be in the
marching band we should
make one yeah we can make one we have
the instrument i want to be the symbol
i play bass guitar that's not a marching
band but i'll play whatever you guys
want i could
probably still play
i could just be like one of the lion
girls at this point
it doesn't want to do the dancing none
of these are marching band instruments
that's a classic instrument i wish i
could play
the guitar i wish i could play the
guitar you can
if you want to you can learn nikki let's
not be ridiculous
those learning days are far from
happening i picked it up again guitar
and piano
[Music]
you